until recently it looked like director
scott derrickson would also finish the
second part of dr. strange but then
surprisingly derrickson and Marvel
decided not to work together on this
project anymore
the search for a successor turned out to
be very difficult however many
considered spider-man director Sam Raimi
to be the best pick for the job a few
days ago it was announced that Raimi and
Marvel could actually agree on a
commitment and so Raimi will soon be
involved in the production of Doctor
Strange - the first comments of the
60-year old director followed
immediately in an interview with
comingsoon.net where he talks about an
appearance of Doctor Strange in
spider-man 2 which Raimi also directed
more precisely it's about a scene in
which Daily Bugle editor JD jonah
Jameson and his colleague Ted Hoffman
discuss how they should officially named
the villain dr. Octavius in the
headlines they finally come up with the
idea of simply calling him Doctor
Strange only to discover shortly
afterwards that the name is already
taken Raimi commented with a smile at
the just mentioned scene that no one
could have foreseen that he would
actually be involved in a Doctor Strange
movie regarding the rumor that dr.
strange - is going to be a horror movie
Raimi didn't really give anything away
yet so far there's only a return of
Benedict Cumberbatch's Doctor Strange
elizabeth Olsen s call at which and
another still unknown character from the
MCU confirmed furthermore the plot is
supposed to be connected to the Disney
Plus Series wander vision and Loki the
u.s. release date of Doctor Strange - is
supposed to be the fifth of November
2021 their news about the eagerly
awaited science fiction film adaption
dune the waiting took longer than
expected after the film project was
announced already in 2016 now there are
new exclusive pictures by Vanity Fair
and news from director Denis Villeneuve
himself the film project will not
consist of one but two films as
originally planned to do justice to the
fantasy of the original author Frank
Herbert and his novel published in 1965
until Herbert's death in 1986 the book
sold 12 million copies and has also been
expanded by several sequels this story
revolves around rival aristocratic
houses a messiah a live flowing drug
called Milan or spa
and a giant monster warm in the vast
area of a desert planet the focus is on
Paul Atreides the son of the Duke and
the Messiah who the indigenous people of
the desert planning have long awaited
you can immediately sense that the story
is too complex to become prescient to
film with the running time of just two
hours as you can seen David Lynch flop
film dune the desert planet from 1984
after that follow the miniseries in 2000
and in 2003 and now a new attempt is
about to start to turn Frank Herbert's
successful novel into a major motion
picture how this could look can be seen
in the pictures that were recently
published exclusively back Vanity Fair
among the mark Timothy Shem Elias the
young Paula traders Rebecca Ferguson as
his mother lady Jessica Oscar Isaac as
Paul's father and son die as the
mysterious woman with a glowing blue
eyes other roles include Jason Momoa
Josh Brolin and Sharon Dunkin Brewster
David Bautista and Charlotte Rampling
the first part of dune should be
released this year on December 18 2020
the release date of the second part is
not yet known not everything went
according to plan for the
oscar-nominated and highly acclaimed
school says he filmed the irishman
because at first there was no one in
Hollywood to finance this scene fully
expensive production now looks like
Scorsese's newest movie killer's of the
flower moon will have exactly the same
problem because the actually responsible
films to your Paramount allegedly got
cold feet and there are also some
reasons for this as you can read in the
report of The Wall Street Journal the
budget has risen to 200 million u.s.
dollars if you also take into account
the costs for marketing and promo it
could be hard to get this money back at
the box office so it came as NAT to
happen
since paramount is supposed to have
given Scorsese the official permission
to ask other providers allegedly
Scorsese is curling talks with two major
streaming services Netflix on the one
hand and Apple on the other
neither of them is really big surprise
because while Netflix already released
the irishman Apple TV plus is now adding
more and more exclusive content to its
own streaming service with killers of
the flower moon Apple TV Plus could
claim a top-class film with Leonardo
DiCaprio and Robert De Niro as its own
the plot based on true events centers on
a series of murders in Osage County
Oklahoma in the early 1920s after
huge all deposits were discovered there
on Native American land an unprecedented
chain of deaths began all of which
greatly benefited the rich farmer
William Hale played by Robert De Niro it
doesn't take long for the FBI to send a
young agent again played by Leonardo
DiCaprio to Oklahoma to investigate the
matter it quickly becomes clear that
it's not so easy to find evidence
because more and more potential
witnesses died under suspicious
circumstances ska Cesar uses a
nonfiction book by journalist David gren
published in 2017 as a direct model in
which the author concludes that farmer
Hale must have killed hundreds of people
Scorsese himself describes the project
as a Western and also works closely with
local Native American community knows
each county to faithfully capture the
history and culture on film a release
date for killers of a flower moon is
unfortunately not fixed at this time it
has already been ten years since Tron
Legacy celebrated its worldwide cinema
review sometime later the announcement
of the third part followed which was put
on hold since then fans have not given
up hope
rightfully so as we now saw a few days
ago when director Kaczynski delivered
good news in a recent interview with
comicbook.com he explained that there
has always been interested in the
sequence and that it is still an
important franchise for Disney he
himself believes that it's going to
happen provided of course that the right
conditions and timing are in place the
sequel to the original film released in
1982 brought Disney only 400 million box
office takings with production cost of
170 million u.s. dollars and therefore
fell short of expectations to what
extent Disney will decide for a third
part remains to be seen
[Music]